the way in which business runs today is
not the way business is always run
um and the philosophies we have in
espouse about quote unquote capitalism
um is not adam smith capitalism
adam smith believed the customer came
first and that the purpose of
of of of capitalism was um consumption
not production
um and uh um and milton friedman in the
mid 1970s i don't have to tell this
group this group already knows all
about his work defined the purpose of
business
the responsibility of business to
maximize profit that was the only item
on his list
he saw businesses very one-dimensional
and unfortunately
his philosophies were completely
embraced and used as a foundation for
new ways to view capitalism
and especially in the 80s and 90s which
were boom years we had cannot forget
relative peace in the world um uh
and we saw the rise of things like
shareholder supremacy which didn't
really exist prior
not to the degree we have it today we
saw the rise of massive amounts of
short-termism
we saw the rise of changing the way in
which we incentivized
our executives based on the price of
inequity rather than the performance of
the company
those two things don't you often don't
necessarily have to go together
um we started to see
the acceptance of using mass layoffs on
a regular basis
to manage the books think about that
companies use people's livelihoods
to meet arbitrary projections they're
profitable just not as profitable as
they promised so you lose your job
and now they wonder why a young
generation is completely disloyal and
shows no
loyalty companies that's because they've
grown up in a world where their parents
got laid off
through no fault of their own it was not
a meritocracy anymore
and we i we we idolized people like jack
welch who did more damage for american
business than
probably almost any leader we've had and
so
and anybody who speaks out against the
form of capitalism we have is accused of
being a socialist these days which is
nuts
i'm a die-hard capitalist but we have
bastardized
capitalism we have to return to a time
where capitalism exists
more for just profit but it exists on
three levels
which is to advance a purpose um to
uh protect people uh um take care of
people
and make profit absolutely profit is is
essential
but not the cost of people and not at
the cost of advancing
something bigger than ourselves the
purpose of companies is to offer value
and value means that you're producing
something you're
you're you're making a product or
selling a service
that in some way shape or form enhances
um the life
of people or companies or society
whether you make our life a little
easier a little more fun a little more
convenient it doesn't matter that's what
value is value is a percep the
perception
that you have somehow made my life
better it's not a calculation
and i think we need to we need to make
um the definition and responsibility of
business
more dynamic than than we currently use
um in the current definition
um to to advance profit within the
bounds of the law what about
what about ethics what about ethics and
just look at any
congressional hearing when there's some
sort of uncomfortable dealings that a
business is having
you know wells fargo you know opening up
millions of fake bank accounts or a
pharmaceutical company with a patent on
an essential drug
raising the price of that drug 500 800 a
thousand 1200 percent
and they all say the same ridiculous
thing when they're testifying in front
of congress
we broke no law we do anything illegal
true 100 true
didn't do anything illegal but it's
highly unethical
and i think we need to restore that um
uh into business and
what we will find is that people will
restore their faith
in companies we're seeing a rise of
populism
around the world that's not coming from
nowhere that's a response to something
and uh and and some of the capitalists
that run the world right now
they defend the status quo predominantly
because they benefit from it
but i think it has to change before it
collapses